i think i've been patient stuart timpa
works as a dealer at one of the las
vegas strip casinos and although
hospitality workers are considered
essential under the state's vaccine
playbook
we haven't heard anything about any
scheduling of any appointments
timpa is 61 years old and says given his
job he would feel safer with a shot
i've been exposed to thousands of people
and i've been lucky enough not to have
contracted the virus but
you know i don't want to push my luck so
now he's planning
to show up at a vaccination site as it's
closing
maybe i would get one then and that's
something some people claim they've
already done on social media many are
calling them vaccine hunters
this person commenting on our facebook
page that's how i got my vaccine i
waited around and there were several
that were going to go to waste
this person writing i would rather the
dose go to someone rather than be wasted
but the southern nevada health district
tells me they worked through their
appointment system to use their vaccine
supply efficiently
governor steve sisolak is also weighing
in we're seeing rumors
and substantiated examples where people
are getting access to the vaccine
who are not yet eligible it is not
fair and that must stop timpa says all
he wants to do is
try if they say no they say no i'm not
there to bother anyone or
cause any kind of problem